so
after more than 70 years
as queen of scots
elizabeth ii is taken
into the palace
and will be placed
in the throne room
peacefully at rest overnight
before the ceremonies begin tomorrow
and she's taken to the high kirk of
saint giles
where a service of thanksgiving for her
life of service to scotland
will take place in the presence
of his majesty the king
the queen
is home
god
ah
go tomorrow we'll form three rides
right
so
[Music]
wow
the guard of honour with the king's
color taking leave of this sad
sight here
at holyrood so different
from when the queen arrived and
many of these soldiers gave their own
salute to the arrival of their queen
but today they've shown their ultimate
respect
on the instructions of the new king to
the late queen as they now leave out
towards
arthur's seat and the glorious views
that this great palace has
of
the hills that sit right within the
heart of the city
as scotland has brought home
the late queen from the highlands here
to the heart of edinburgh